morning everybody it's seven o'clock
here in the uk you are very welcome to
spend your breakfast with us here at sky
news this morning the prime minister
says the fuel supply crisis is
stabilizing so
why we're being told it's highly likely
that army deliveries will begin within
days to get petrol pumping again
and how many garages are still running
short we'll ask industry experts plus
the shadow justice secretary david lammy
on the programme later on and changing
faces why are good guys in movies so
often glamorous while the villains are
frequently scarred or visibly different
we speak to the charity calling for
people with a disfigurement to be given
positive roles
in movies
and food for positive thought as new
research finds children who eat more
fruit and veg enjoy significantly
improved mental health we'll be joined
by mob kitchen's boss ben liebers who'll
be cooking up a healthy dish for kids
live it's wednesday the 29th of
september defense source tells us it's
highly likely army deliveries will begin
within days to help get petrol pumping
the prime minister says things are
stabilizing but still cues are
forming getting to a point where
i may not be able to make my shift
you know to get to work so it's not
ideal when you work in a hospital
i'm here at a petrol station in surrey
to see if commuters outside of london
are facing problems filling up here
they've had no fuel since monday
[Music]
and a new danger rivers of lava from the
farmers volcano reached the ocean
creating clouds of toxic gas
concerned for her well-being an
emotional statement from katie price's
family
after the star is reportedly involved in
a car crash
it's the biggest speech of his career
here in brighton kierstarma prepares to
deliver labour's pitch for government
license to thrill which of these outfits
do you like best we'll have all the
action from the bond premier and we'll
be reviewing the film to see
if it's any good
the britney spears conservatorship case
returns to court here in los angeles
with her father possibly about to be
removed from control
[Music]
and the mighty real madrid beaten in the
champions league by a team from the land
that football forgot
[Music]
good morning everybody if you're running
on empty this morning it's a bit of a
mixed picture the prime minister says
the fuel supply crisis is stabilizing
but defence sources say it's highly
likely army deliveries will begin within
days according to the latest figures
from the petrol retailers association
around a third of garages are still
short on fuel as shinge maruriki reports
could scenes like this one be coming to
an end
the prime minister thinks so
but britain's largest fuel companies are
more guarded saying the situation is
beginning to stabilize with the pressure
at the pumps easing
despite that there are more tailbacks
and tensions at some forecourts
including this rather novel use of a
water bottle
there was also this violent response to
a cue jumper which saw one man pull out
a knife at a station in welling
southeast london
the met police has since confirmed the
incident is being looked into
speaking to k burley on sky news a fuel
campaigner made the case for military
assistance
the only thing we can do at the moment
to get back to some sort of
normality is to get the 100 200 military
drivers to actually start delivering to
four cops because the all of the tankers
refineries are full up with diesel and
petrol ready to go we just need some
drivers bums on seats
he could be getting his wish
last night a minister of defense source
said that it was highly likely around
150 military personnel could start
driving tankers like these ones if and
when required
one place where supply chain issues are
still being felt is this bp station in
oxford
it had been closed since 8am in the
morning after running out of petrol but
still a carousel of cars drove through
looking for their fill
it's getting to a point where
i may not be able to make my shift
you know to get to work so um it's not
ideal when you work in a hospital or
anywhere really i think they're trying
to calm people down is what they're
trying to do which is understandable
but um
my mum didn't make it to my house the
other night i had to get a jerry can to
bring this car back
with many pumps still out of action and
queues across the country not even the
army can promise a quick end to this
crisis
okay let's get the latest on the supply
crisis from the four court aisha joining
us now and sorry hello to aisha good
morning what about the um petrol station
behind you what's the situation there
good morning kay well it's a really dire
situation here massive problems for
commuters people trying to get to work
people trying to head out on the school
run because there is no fuel here and
there hasn't been since monday they ran
out around 8 p.m monday evening and
didn't get a delivery yesterday they say
they expect a delivery today but they
don't know what time that that could
potentially arrive this evening so it
could mean another day with this
forecourt largely
closed off now that hasn't stopped
people from arriving we've seen
a steady stream of cars pass throughout
the morning and some even queued up
before the station opened before six
o'clock this morning hoping they could
get their hands on some but having no
luck this station is just one
of 37 according to the re according to
the petrol retailers association which
doesn't have any fuel on the forecourt
now we did hear from the government and
industry experts yesterday saying that
the situation is showing early signs of
stabilizing but they're still
encouraging people to go back to their
normal buying habits uh and in the
meantime we could expect to see more
scenes like this throughout the day and
potentially the next few days okay aisha
thank you very much indeed thanks a lot
still to come on the programme for you
this morning 7 30 speaking to the
organization calling for an urgent
change to mindset to tackle rising
emissions
changing faces we speak to campaigners
who want to see actors with visible
differences playing positive roles not
just always being cast as the bad guy
and after 9 00 am discussing new
research suggesting children who eat
more fruit and veg are happier joined by
a professor of nutritional epidemiology
and also ben libous will cook us a happy
meal
rivers of lava from the volcano on la
palma have reached the sea causing
clouds of toxic gas
to form becky is on la palma for us uh
today it's not getting any better becky
is it good morning
hi there k yeah that you're right it's
hit the water that is the thing we were
waiting to see if and when that would
happen and it did around 11 00 p.m last
night it passed through a town called
todoke caused a lot of damage there and
then went over a cliff about a hundred
feet high in to the ocean now the reason
that scientists have been so concerned
about that is that when lava hits the
sea it creates a thermal shock the lava
is over a thousand degrees centigrade
the water is just over 20 degrees
centigrade and that releases toxic gases
containing hydrochloric acid it's
extremely irritating the eyes and the
skin and dangerous to breathe in and
that's why residents in the surrounding
areas have been told to stay inside the
houses do not leave do not breathe in
that gas now the effect of the lava
hitting that water it won't create a
tsunami or anything like that it's not
enough lava to do that it might be
dangerous to some sea life because it
can change the oxygen and the ph levels
but really the main concern with this is
the gas that's being released and making
sure that people don't go out and
breathe it in
and as far as local people are concerned
many of them have lost their homes
they've got issues staying inside given
these toxic chemicals but but thankfully
not no injuries that were to report at
this stage
no exactly miraculously no one has been
injured um speaking to locals this
volcanic eruption compared to the
previous two which are the only two
really that the older people on the
island can remember this volcanic
eruption is worse because it has passed
through more houses but thankfully the
evacuation orders were put in place
early enough that people did manage to
get out of course as you say a lot of
damage running into the tens of millions
of people now left homeless and actually
we found out yesterday that surprisingly
although there's so many volcanoes on
this island a lot of people don't have
insurance and they fear that the
government aid that is being supplied
simply won't cover all of their houses
okay becky thank you thanks a lot
dramatic pictures continuing from la
palma where the um volcanic ash has now
reached the sea reducing toxic chemicals
and toxic gas i will keep an eye on that
for you of course as becky was saying
miraculously no injuries or deaths as a
result of that volcano continuing to
erupt
in other news katie price's families say
they are concerned for some time about
her mental well-being after she was
reportedly involved in a car crash the
former glamour model is said to have
been arrested on suspicion of driving
under the influence of alcohol and drugs
near a home in west sussex a police
officer posted a picture of a vehicle
believed to be that being driven by the
43 year old when she crashed her vehicle
she recently confirmed she's banned from
driving until the end of the year
in the statement the prize family wrote
as a family we have for some time been
concerned about kate's well-being and
overhaul overall mental health today our
worst fears nearly came true as a family
we have been and will continue to help
kate get the help she needs we hope that
she will realize that she cannot battle
her issues alone
the family we've also asked the media
and public to give katie price the space
to seek the necessary treatment that she
needs last year katie price was
convicted of being nearly twice the
limit while in charge of her range rover
which she later sold at auction
now after 18 months of covid enforced
delays daniel crade's swan song as james
bond no time to die has finally had its
big night on the red carpet
after a 15-year stint as the world's
most famous spy craig is hanging up his
gadgets having appeared as bond in five
movies he hit the red carpet on tuesday
in a rather striking pink blazer
he was joined at the premiere by a host
of vips including members of the royal
family kate the duchess of cambridge
stealing the show in a golden gown
the event at the albert hall was a real
who's who uh the teenage tennis
sensation emma radicanu attended the
premiere as well as the likes of billy
eilish who penned the film's soundtrack
actually nile rogers jerry hallowell and
the england captain harry kane was there
as well as our arts and entertainment
correspondent katie spencer reports she
caught up with the man himself on the
red carpet as well as phoebe walla
bridge who was brought on board the film
to bring the franchise into the me to
era
you said you were leaving
then you had to wait 18 months for it to
come out because it just felt like an
extraordinary long time no because we've
had covert so everything has to be put
into perspective doesn't it it's um i'm
greatly relieved we make bomb movies for
the cinema and uh and we're here and uh
i couldn't be happy about that i think
it was m in one of the films who said we
know that bond is this misogynist sexist
dinosaur
was that i mean were you excited to
write for someone like that or did you
just think where do i even start that's
a very pertinent question because yes
yes i am and i was and um but also more
so that daniel's point of view on all of
that has been so
strong um from the beginning and how
he's evolved bond you know i'm really
following his lead but it was fun to be
able to kind of riff on those themes
so with the curtain coming down on his
tenure as double07 let's have a look at
some of daniel craig's best bits in the
role
[Music]
the name's bond
james bond
[Music]
queue
double 07.
[Music]
we'll be discussing whether this was his
best or worst bond we'll have all the
gossip as well as the first reaction to
the film itself with the entertainment
journalist caroline frost at around um
20 past eight this morning so do stay
tuned for that perhaps you were lucky
enough to go to the premiere the royal
premiere last night if so maybe tweet us
and let us know what you thought about
this last bond movie for daniel craig
who might be born next could it be idris
elba we live in hope ladies now the
labour leader kia strama faces what's
been described as the most important
speech of his career today when he
addresses his party conference in
brighton he'll tell them that the party
is back in business and he'll try to put
a clear divide between his policies and
those of his predecessor jeremy corbyn
reporting from brighton here's our
political correspondent kate mccann
it's not just the wind labourers had to
contend with here in brighton
kyostama has been buffeted on both sides
by a party that wants very different
things from him
john mcdonnell has made it clear what
the left wing wants
if he got up
and said i'd like to welcome jeremy
corbyn back into the parliament
[Applause]
it would send a message out to our rank
and file members that we are genuinely
coming together and he's serious about
that
the man himself is going nowhere but
there are lots of people who say that
you shouldn't be here because you are a
distraction for the new leader how do
you feel about that i don't know who
these people are and i don't imagine why
anyone should say such a thing i'm very
happy to be here and enjoying conference
and enjoying meeting many friends and
comrades
others just want to move forward to win
elections again kierstrama agrees
i want to move the party to a position
where it focuses on what matters to
working families i'm moving it from a
party that's inward to a part of it
outward and moving apart it looks
backward so a party looks forward
and the members who want clarity and
direction but still aren't sure if
they've got the right man for the job
the one thing that i've been wanting and
wanting from the leadership is you know
bold ambitious policy and i don't feel
like that that desire to see that has
been matched we made so many strides
forward and it's a pity that we've gone
backwards in time with uh the current
system so i'm hoping that kia builds on
the legacy that we had when we were in
government last time i mean i'm hoping
for it to sort of be a call for unity
and also to sort of lay out at least in
broad steps a sort of policy direction
where the leopard has been going
a lot of the chatter at this party
conference has been about internal party
politics but today when sarkistarma
steps onto that stage he's got the
chance to really talk to the country at
large it's what the party members want
but it's what voters want too to know if
winning really matters more to the
labour leader than party unity
if he does today is the moment to be
bold to set out how labour will win the
next election and cast aside the
policies of the past that have failed to
do just that then it's for voters to
decide if his plan can turn the tide and
return the party to power kate mccann
sky news in brighton
tomorrow is also in brighton for us
today and it's leader speech day today
tomorrow good morning
morning kay yes big moment for kirstama
his first in-person speech to a party
conference since becoming leader he's
had to give many of his speeches on zoom
from his living room so this is his his
first encounter with the activists and
although you heard someone there talking
about unity it's clear from the extracts
that we've been given of the speech that
kierstama is going to be very much
talking about winning he'll talk about
getting labor back in business and not
the failed policies of the past we're
told this is going to be an optimistic
and a forward-looking speech but the
backdrop to this conference has very
much been roused with the left of his
party both on policies and also on the
party rules and those around kierstarma
say that he now needs to forge his own
path and if the left don't want to come
with him then they will be falling by
the wayside two big policies in this
speech one on mental health saying if
labour get into government anyone who
needs mental health support will get it
within a month and a big recruitment
drive for teachers
delegates here will assess whether that
represents the radical program for
government they were looking for but i
think the key thing today is that
kierstama who's seen as quite cautious
quite risk-averse finds his voice and
manages to convince not just delegates
here but voters out there that winning
elections is not just something he talks
about is actually within his grasp okay
tomorrow for now thank you
well the labour leader has been uh
contacting industry leaders to ask um
about the president's situation and how
potentially it can be fixed not just as
far as a fuel shortages our concern but
a lot of shortages within the
hospitality industry as well just not
enough waiters and other hospitality
staff to be able to keep restaurants
open seven days a week well kate
nicholls is the chief executive of um uk
um hospitality uh joining us now hello
to you kate thanks for joining us um
what did you say to the labor leader
well what we took forward was was an
overview of the impact of the covid
crisis on the hospitality sector and the
current challenges our members are
facing simply because of high staff
shortages across the sector and across
the economy as a whole so hospitality
hit with a double whammy really we've
got 10 vacancy rate in our own
businesses that's everything from from
front of house waiters bar staff but
also restaurant managers skilled
executive chefs
and then we're also hit with shortages
in our supply chain and the net effect
of that has been that our businesses
have not been able to open fully over
the summer a quarter of hospitality
businesses saying that they've had to
close on one day a week or reduce their
hours of operating in order to manage
the demand and supply manage the staff
shortages coming through
and that means that revenues continue to
be suppressed so we do need support from
the government and and that was the
message we took to the leader of the
opposition yesterday
what does 10
shortage equate to
uh it's about one in 10 of our workforce
at the moment so when we're operating at
full strength that's around 300 000
workers that are short at the moment
obviously as a result of kovid sadly the
hospitality sector has had to let many
people go so we've got a current vacancy
rate of about 180 000 workers that we
are short and that just means we cannot
operate at full capacity we cannot start
the process of recovering and rebuilding
those shattered balance sheets and
contributing to the positive economic
growth that we know we can do
and what would you like the government
to try to do about it we know that uh
hgv drivers are going to be given a
limited waiver on visas in order to come
from the continent to help um is that
something that your industry is looking
at
well we would like to see a covered
recovery visa clearly the issues that
we're facing at the moment are that lots
of our workers are stuck abroad because
of travel restrictions unable to return
home a lot of hospitality workers went
home to see their families over
christmas and of course hospitality was
shut down completely
in a six-month lockdown as a result of
that so we would like to see the
government extending that that welcome
back to those workers lifting those
travel restrictions on them as soon as
possible and also then simplifying the
the immigration rules at the moment to
to improve and reduce the bureaucracy
for us to get staff in it's quite clear
that we don't have sufficient workers in
the labor market at the moment to fill
all those roles we're doing our bit but
we've got a two-year delay in a hiatus
in our talent pipeline as we simply
haven't been able to train chefs and
skilled workers over the last two years
have covered so we do need help to get
over that
bump
before we can reinvest in in our own
apprenticeships
and have you approached the government
uh in that regard and what have they
said
well we do continue to have ongoing
dialogue with the government explaining
to them the impact that we've we've seen
across the sector of those job shortages
and labour shortages how it's
constraining our ability to help with
the economic recovery we know that
government is listening and is concerned
to support the sector but so far we
haven't seen any changes of the kind
we've seen in respect of poultry
processors and hgv drivers but these are
sticking plaster that will help part of
the supply chain it won't help
hospitality how can you cope uh without
180 between 130 and 180 000 um staff
shortages especially leading into the
festive period
we simply can't cope i mean
our businesses will not be able to
operate fully they've been closed over
parts of the summer restaurants are
shutting off parts of their restaurants
or closing them in full parts of the
days of the week hotels are closing off
bedrooms and closing off restaurants to
non-residents and we've seen operating
hours reduced as well as reduced menus
as a result of the food supply chain
crisis with deliveries not getting
through so we're simply not going to be
able to generate the level of revenue
that we could over the course of the
summer revenues have been hit by around
16
with no end in sight to some of the
current shocks that the sector is facing
co2 fuel crisis utility prices on top of
the the
labor shortages in our sector and the
food supply chain we can cannot see that
that changes over the course of the next
three to four months so we're going to
see hospitality revenues back out down
at a round break even these businesses
will continue to remain fragile
okay uh kate nichols um ceo of uk
hospitality thank you for joining us on
the programme much appreciated let's
take you to manchester now should we
bring in um sasha lord he um
joins us to talk about the nighttime
economy heights actually we're hearing
there um about what's happening with
restaurants and the like where some
restaurants are having to close one day
a week because they just don't have
enough staff what about the impact uh on
your uh side of the industry what's
happening there good morning
well good morning kay yeah no i i
reiterate everything that kate just said
um it feels only a few months ago we
were talking about on your program care
recovery and how we're looking forward
to it but actually
since then we've been absolutely
handcuffed you know we talk about the
the staff shortages um as you may
remember i have a festival called
parklife festival that took place three
months ago and working with other
festival organizers across the whole of
the uk we were saying to the government
months ago the start of summer look
there is a huge issue here there aren't
enough polish drivers to bring our
infrastructure
and sadly it fell on deaf ears um i can
tell you again just purely from a
personal level last weekend we traded
without draft we couldn't get the gas um
that the thoughtlet trusts we don't have
the gas for portland trucks this weekend
so we're having to bring the staff in to
manually handle stock around um i know
people with restaurants now how as kate
just said are operating limited menus
limited days there are pubs and bars
across greater manchester and the uk
that will not serve giraffe this weekend
they're just serving bottles and cans
and it feels such a shame you know the
industry
as everybody knows and you've supported
it so well case it's been
devastated for 18 months and we're still
on our knees and it's endless we're
firefighting
what's the one thing that needs to
change urgently
the government i think
they now need to listen um i think
most of the people watching this program
will agree with me that
the government really did not give the
credit to the hospitality industry um
just as we started to shut down and i
understand why
possibly you know pubs bars restaurants
theaters you go to those places to enjoy
yourselves with your friends you let
your hair down so they didn't really
give us the credit that we were the
fifth biggest industry
in the whole of the uk
um i think as time moved on he started
to understand that and he saw the public
reaction and how badly we were treated
you know today this morning
it's been announced that there's going
to be a hospitality
council um which
is great but it feels to me as if the
horse has already bolted perhaps that
should have been announced
18 months ago and when i look at the
names sat around the table and again i
do welcome this but when there are names
there like deliveroo
starbucks nando's um you know that's not
really a true reflection of the local
family independence no dare the voices
the large corporations have the huge
bank loans but actually the people
who've suffered the most are those small
independents that have borrowed money or
friends or family someone couldn't get
bank loans but they had bounced back
loans
so it will take another three years at
least to recover and and the one thing i
would say k to anybody watching this now
from governments is
look you're going to put v80 up to 12.5
in a few days time furlough falls away
you absolutely must continue v80 at that
level for at least another three years
to help the industry to recover that
would be my one big ask
because i fear that if you don't do that
and you pull the rug it's too soon it's
too quick and we will see many more
businesses close
what about a covid recovery visa that we
were hearing there from kate nicholls do
you think that's a good idea
i think it's a fantastic idea we've been
calling for this for weeks it's it's an
absolute no-brainer for me it will fill
the hole it will fill the gap but i've
been watching your program last night
okay and and this morning as well and
we've been looking at
the difference how well haulage drivers
are treated in europe versus how they're
treated in the uk and i don't understand
why they would come back if i've been
completely honest with you um
but yeah that let's expedia these visas
let's cut through the red tape let's not
mess around and let's not talk about
this for weeks and weeks and weeks we
need urgency and this needs to be done
now
and what can um people who come to the
pubs and bars do to try to to help i
mean we did the eat out to help out last
august it didn't go quite according to
plan as far as the government was
concerned are people coming back now and
if they are are they taking necessary
measures to try to stop the spread of
covert
they are the public on the whole have
been fantastic you know there are a
minority who
you know are impatient they need to
understand these stuff shortages and
these these product shortages you know
it's sometimes service might be slower
it might be a limited menu just please
bear with us remember you know you can't
just click your finger and return back
to normal the industry is rusty we have
been shot for 18 months but on the whole
they've been really supportive i do have
a slight concern that as
and i've said this all along the larger
the city centre the harder it's going to
be to recover and we've been trying to
get people back into the city center
and obviously with the haulage crisis
now people might start to work a bit
more at home
so that's at the forefront of my
thoughts today but yeah on the whole the
public have been fantastic in supporting
the industry
um thanks for getting up early for us
sasha it's great to talk to you as
always thank you
thank you
sentencing of the former police officer
who murdered sarah everard is due to
begin later on today wayne cousins
pleaded guilty to the kidnap rape and
murder of the 33 year old in july of
this year
sarah everard's body was found in
woodland near ashford in kent meters
from land owned by the former met
officer
there are calls for the cruise ship
industry to be effectively regulated to
minimise the serious risk it poses to
human health researchers say cruise
ships are a potential source of
infectious diseases to passengers staff
and residents who live near ports
real madrid at home to sharif turspul in
the champions league a team from a
breakaway state in moldova
one of the european greats against lowly
qualifiers surely
it had to be a cricket score well
not quite sharif tirispal i think that's
how i pronounced it pulled off an
enormous shock as they won 2-1 at real
madrid thanks to a sensational 89th
minute strike
the club is from the unrecognized
breakaway state of
transnistria you know where that is
don't you
population under half a million and it's
the first time they've qualified for the
competition
the birth of a rare female
arabian leopard has brought hope for an
endangered species the cub was born in
april at the arabian leopard breeding
center in tafe
in
saudi arabia as part of a special
breeding program that hopes to release
more of the big cats into the wild
the arabian leopard is the smallest
member of the leopard family its top
weight of about 30 kilos is half that of
its african cousin it's thought that
only 200 of this species remain in the
wild after centuries of habitat lost
and
human conflict human conflict meaning of
course that they are shot
thankfully
we've seen one bred in captivity we'll
speak to the organization calling for an
urgent change of mindset to tackle
rising emissions that to come in just a
moment
[Music]
well the basic idea is that students
require demand climate change and
education and for as long as they're not
going to get it from the state from
government they're going to try and
teach their teachers themselves the idea
is that you know like you reverse the
classroom
you do what is needed
and there's a huge demand around the
world climate change is the major the
most significant crisis of our
civilization and yet our schools are
doing almost nothing to empower students
to empower teachers to prepare for the
future and i think this is an incredible
demonstration of will and engagement by
the younger generations we are seeing an
incredible demonstration of
responsibility from the younger
generation i think they feel it more
than the adult generation and again they
are not simply demanding they are saying
if we don't do it if you don't do it
we're going to do it ourselves we're
going to take it in our own hands and i
think in a sense this is an important
uh message to uh the uk government the
italian government they're help
co-hosting the the cup conference at the
end of this year in glasgow and
something radical has to happen and we
often focus on the energy transition on
the technological transition but
education is just as important if not
more important because it allows us to
change the behavior of billions and
billions of people schools are powerful
institutions in leading this
transformation across the world not just
in europe not just in the west but
across the entire globe what the
students are demanding and what some of
us have been pioneering around the world
is a different type of approach we need
to empower people we need to teach and
explore new ways of doing things how do
we act on climate change how do we slow
down climate change how do we um engage
communities in doing something about it
students don't want to know that the
planet is coming to an end they want to
know what they can do to fix it and that
is the kind of education this empowering
education
that we're missing at this stage
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
[Music]
hello again everybody hospitality owners
say they'll continue to struggle to cope
right up to christmas after 18 months of
devastation due to the pandemic they're
now facing severe staff shortages and on
top of that supply difficulties with
food and also with fuel kate nichols the
head of uk hospitality says they need
help
our businesses will not be able to
operate fully they've been closed over
parts of the summer restaurants are
shutting off parts of their restaurants
or closing them in full parts of the
days of the week hotels are closing off
bedrooms and closing off restaurants to
non-residents and we've seen operating
hours reduced as well as reduced menus
as a result of the food supply chain
crisis with deliveries not getting
through so we're simply not going to be
able to generate the level of revenue
that we could over the course of the
summer revenues have been hit by around
16
with no end in sight to some of the
current shocks that the sector is facing
co2 fuel crisis utility prices on top of
the the labor shortages in our sector
and the food supply chain we can cannot
see that that changes over the course of
the next three to four months so we're
going to see hospitality revenues back
out down at around break even these
businesses will continue to remain
fragile
a new report from the risk management
group dnv is calling for an urgent
change of mindset to bring down global
emissions that chimes with what the
climate activist greta tumbo told scania
she said that the uk is a climate
villain just a month before it hosts the
cop 26 climate conference
it's very easy
to to make it seem like they are taking
leadership and it's i find it very
strange that
they're like they are the ones who we
are supposed to look up to now
but they are
objectively one of the biggest climate
villains
um which i find very strange
joining us now is harriet van gevin
regional director of uk and ireland
energy system at dnv hello thanks for
joining us let me just pick up on that
from greta tumber could i do you think
that the uk is one of the biggest
climate villains
um
good morning and thanks for having me on
i think it's important to remember this
in the context of an energy transition
um the world in many ways is an energy
villain because we've used fossil fuels
to power our economies for the last uh
for the last 50 years so what's
important is to focus on the energy
transition and greenhouse gas emissions
reduction
um okay so talk to me about um in in the
report it says a massive redirection of
spending from carbon heavy investment
into clean energy is required how do we
do that then
well maybe if we take a step back and in
your introduction you reference cop 26
in a month's time in glasgow but if we
go back to perhaps the last very
successful cop was back in uh 2015 the
paris agreement cop 21 and there the
governments of the world came together
and agreed on a plan to limit uh global
warming and greenhouse gas emissions to
1.5 degrees um dmv's energy forecast is
basically showing that we will have used
that greenhouse gas emissions budget um
or carbon budget as it's sometimes
referred to we would have used that 1.5
degrees by 2029.
we would have used the 2 degree carbon
budget by 2053 and by the end of the
century global warming will be at 2.3
degrees above pre-industrial levels and
i think your channel does a great job
every evening of highlighting the
challenges and consequences associated
with that global warming yeah we've got
a climate dashboard actually that we can
look at as we're talking to you
is clean energy
affordable just looking at the numbers
and the amount of fossil fuels and
renewables etc that being used at the
moment and also that time left before we
reach one and a half degrees celsius
many experts saying that's the point of
no return we're presently suggesting
that's um 11 years away you think that's
potentially before that um we need to
change everybody agrees with that the
question is how expensive is it going to
be to do that
yeah i mean i think these dashboards are
great to focus our mind for where we are
today but there is some good news in our
forecast um the energy mix is changing
so in 2019
um
the world was using about 80 percent
of its energy needs was met by fossil
fuels and only 20
uh by non-fossil fuels uh our forecast
is showing by 2050 that picture is going
to change uh 50
will come from fossil fuel but 50 from
non-fossil fuels and the bulk of that
non-fossil fuels will come from
renewable energy from wind and solar so
the energy mix is changing and the clean
energy transition is happening
but as you correctly highlight it's just
not happening fast enough so we need to
accelerate it and we need to figure out
how to finance it
um fascinating stuff thank you so much
for your expertise appreciate you
joining us this morning on the program
thank you
thank you
um
let's uh change patients britney spears
could finally see her father removed
from the conservatorship that's
controlled her life and money for more
than a decade in a highly awaited court
ruling an la judge will today decide
whether jaime spears who took on the
role after the star suffered a mental
health breakdown in 20 in 2008 must now
step down as greg milan reports from los
angeles
for the movement that mobilized in their
words to free brittany the victory
that's within sight is no reason to go
quiet now
[Music]
they took their protest to the offices
of the singers management company with
new questions about her treatment
today's court hearing though is likely
to be another moment of vindication
in january of this year we were still
being called conspiracy theorists often
i said free britney for the first time
in 2009 it's been a long time coming
he's never had one person
the story of the conservatorship that's
run britney's life continues to fuel
more new documentaries
this one containing explosive claims
they openly talked about monitoring her
their their reason for the monitoring
was you know looking for bad influence
looking for potential you know illegal
activity that might happen
but they would also monitor
conversations with
her friends
um with her mom
with
her lawyer sam ingham
if there's anybody that should be off
limits it should be britney's lawyer
the conservators and their security firm
have denied those allegations
britney does seem likely to get her away
and have her father jamie removed as
conservator the whole arrangement one
she says has ruined her life could end
within weeks
for these supporters it is now about
more than just what they call freedom
for britney spears they want an
investigation into what's happened over
the last 13 years and for the hundreds
of thousands of other people subject to
conservative ships to get their own
protections
it's an issue that's now reached
washington talk of a change in the law
and now a congressional hearing
if the conservatorship process can
deprive someone like miss spears
someone with immense celebrity immense
wealth immense material success
of her fundamental liberties
then what chance does the average
american have
what britney spears thinks we can gauge
from her social media posts it's all in
the past she wrote today though will do
much to determine her future
greg milam sky news los angeles
[Music]
coming up on the program for you
changing faces we speak to a campaigner
who wants to see actors with visible
differences play other roles not just
villains
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's decisively
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
did you know that if we all work
together we can really make a difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah we should really do that
it's a chilly start today with some
scattered showers the showers will
mainly be in the west otherwise there'll
be plenty of sunny spells although it
will feel rather cool in the brisk
breeze cloud will thicken across ireland
and northern ireland as the next weather
system approaches bringing rain and
strong winds to the west coast later
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high
breezy conditions from the northwest
will give low levels of air pollution
today
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now elsaleen is the first miss great
britain contestant to compete in all
three rounds
without makeup she she was placed
actually in the top five and won the miz
publicity gb 2021
title
well elle is with us now hello to you
hi good morning hi
what made you do this
um so there was a numerous um
there was numerous reasons mainly for my
own mental health and my own recovery
with that journey um but also to remind
women that they have a choice to do what
they want to do there's so much pressure
on women and in the media even at the
moment we see it all over to look a
certain way to be a certain way and my
stance was that women have a choice to
wear makeup or not they have a choice to
do what they want with their bodies and
no one should tell them otherwise
another reason i did this was because
there's a lot of apps at the moment
online which are targeting young people
and as a mental health worker i'm aware
of the suicide rates and what those are
and also the reasons why and a lot of
young people are ending their lives
sadly because of low self-esteem and
body dysmorphia and my stance was all
about that as well it was all about
reminding the next generation the
promise to the next generation that we
will do better for them and we will do
what we can to support a next movement
to just be okay with who you are it's as
simple as that and i mean yeah are
absolutely stunning even without me if
it has to be said what what reaction did
you have from the of the contestants
when you
arrived and they said well are you
putting your makeup on you said no this
is me
um they were really supportive they were
really supportive as women in the 2020
world and with children some of them
themselves they understood completely
what i was doing the organizers as well
were really supportive of me and i can't
ask for for more of that for more than
that really it was an amazing experience
i was quite nervous when i went on the
stage i got to the end of the platform
and i thought this is it i can't go back
now i will be falling off this platform
if i do um
and then yeah it just it just worked
really well and the judges called me
brave the head judge said that i was
really brave and she commended that
which was amazing and it was such a nice
feeling i'm still coming down from from
that if i'm honest i'm still
in in cloud nine
with everything that's been going on
it's been an amazing response and that's
what it's all about it's about having
these conversations discussing this
openly and making this a normality one
day
so what next for you
um so next i'm going to be arranging a
petition
and the petition is about schools
talking openly about these things in
lessons this was discussed with me and
the department of education not long ago
and actually it's not a compulsory
requirement so that's my next step uh my
next step is to get into as many
campaigns as possible and keep this
alive and keep this being talked about
um i've got some events coming up near
christmas um and i'm just i've got the
fuel now this is where the hard work
starts do you never wear makeup
um i used to i used to have a really um
unhealthy relationship with it actually
but now no i've decided to let my skin
breathe a little bit and just embrace
who i am and the lock down definitely
showed me that i was able to do that
that really helped me with the pressures
around conforming and showing up as a
woman in the 21st century i was able to
just wear a mask go to the supermarket
i was bullied in school when i was
younger for my parents i was ridiculed
for that as my
olive skin
and
thicker hair was something that the
other kids maybe didn't understand at
that age when you don't understand
something you ridicule it and those
words that the bully said to me all
those years came with me into adulthood
they came with me i was repeating these
things that they were saying without
even really realizing it myself and then
during lockdown i thought hold on a
minute what am i do you know what am i
doing and and that showed me that i had
a lot to work on and i did all of that
work and i
yeah i've come out the end a different
person actually i don't recognize that
person i was and if i wear makeup it's
because it's my choice not because i
want the validation from a complete
stranger uh to tell me that i'm good
enough and that for me is a very
liberating obviously beautiful inside
and out thank you so much for taking the
time to join us this morning thank you
thanks a lot
well after 18 months of covered enforced
delays daniel crade swan song as james
bond
no time to die has finally had its big
night on the red carpet there he is
wearing a tom ford jacket i'm sure
you've got a view on that it's um it's
velvet and daniel craig hit the red
carpet uh in a as i said rather striking
fuchsia let's call it fuchsia laser
so often the villains in movies
including the recent bond movie have
scars or disfigurements which leads to
negative representation campaigners are
calling for a change when it comes to
visible differences and have launched a
new campaign video to change that with a
james bond theme
i had convinced myself that in this
industry i would never ever be
attractive enough or good enough to play
james bond and i think that comes from
as a child myself growing up and
watching
villains with scars all over the tv
people with visible differences are the
true heroes we go through so much in our
day-to-day life
and
[Music]
i think we deserve a bit of heroism
joining us now campaigner and charity
ambassador tulsi faggiani thank you so
much for joining us um tulsi and in the
latest bond movie the buddy has a facial
disfigurement don't they
yeah good morning kay so nice to see you
again and you too and you too tell me
about the campaign
so this campaign you know came about so
you know working with changing faces
with a campaign for people with a
visible difference often we get messages
saying you know i've experienced a
negative message i've been compared to a
you know a villain in a film myself
included i got referred to as freddy
krueger
so the more we heard this
you know the more we realize we need to
campaign for change in popular culture
and film and tv
and you know three years ago we launched
the same kind of concept i'm not your
villain
and the british film institute um
you know pledged to say that they won't
be funding any and further films with a
villain um with the disfigurement
now here we are you know james bond and
yet again the villain has a
disfigurement
and it's just bringing back brings about
a really negative connotation and we
need to change this you know um not just
for the generation now but those that
sort of who are really young at the
moment and you know going through their
own journey with having a visible
difference
so that's how this campaign comes about
and you've done a fantastic video to
accompany um the campaign i'm not your
villain just tell me a little bit more
i'm sure we can have a look at that and
tell me a little bit more about the
campaign
yeah so the campaign is just to you know
call to action that um leno let's talk
about you know having a better
representation for those with a visible
difference you know we should be a hero
a heroine in a film we should be a love
interest you know we should be the main
leading role i mean look at rob he just
plays the most amazing bond you know
look how amazing he looks so why can't
he play bond and as we know you know
james bond amount of times he's been
like you know shot out he's fallen off
buildings like surely he should have
sustained a scar or something by now you
know so it's not actually real is it so
i think we just need to show a bit more
realism out there was that you as audrey
hepburn in that um
it sure was she's my style eye concert
to be able to you know dress up like her
and channel my inner audrey hepburn was
just incredible and again it just shows
that anything is possible and
i too can you know play audrey hepburn
if i had to or if i wanted to and this
is the thing we should all be able to
have a choice
have you found that the public has
changed its perception over the years
are we more tolerant of people who are
different to us
i think we are you know things are
changing definitely but i just think in
terms of visual representation which is
like your media you know films and tv we
definitely need to do a lot more um
just because like look one in five
identify having a visible difference
that's quite a lot and that's a lot of
people who are experiencing a lot of
negative comments out there you know
being compared to someone on the screen
as a villain i grew up with that i
thought having scars was a bad thing or
i was a bad person just because i was
compared to freddy krueger now that's
not really healthy and we need to change
that
okay chelsea it's good to talk to you
thank you so much for joining us on the
program thank you
coming up in the next hour here on the
program taking you back to la paloma
where we have
seen the volcano eruption continuing and
now the lava has reached the sea which
has released a significant amount of
gases which are harmful to humans
the sea is about 20 degrees the lava's
about a thousand degrees they get
together and cause all sorts of problems
bringing you the very latest on that and
indeed taking it back down to labour
party conference where david lammy will
be speaking to us very shortly indeed
all that to come through
[Music]